zuschauer und sie sehen sie schon bei
mir im hintergrund das
bundesverteidigungsministerium
christine lambrecht die bundeswehr kauft
neue flugzeuge wir hören jetzt einfach
in ihr statement rhein in berlin
bezüglich den in die jahre gekommenen
tornado dafür die nachfolge zu
beschaffen seit über zwei jahren wird
hier eine lösung gesucht und es war
wichtig dass diese lösung jetzt schnell
getroffen wird und deswegen haben wir
die entscheidung gefällt dass wir nach
sorgfältiger betrachtung aller optionen
die auf dem tisch lagen habe ich mich
entschieden für die aufgabe der
nuklearen teilhabe die beschaffung von
flugzeugen des typs f-35 einzuleiten die
f35 bietet ein einzigartiges
kooperationsprojekt
mit unseren nato verbündeten und
weiteren partnern in europa und für die
rolle des elektronischen kampf haben wir
uns für die weiterentwicklung des
eurofighters entschieden und damit
bleibt wichtige schlüsseltechnologie in
deutschland und in europa darüber hinaus
sichern wir uns eine starke deutsche
rolle im zukünftigen system f kasten und
das will ich ganz klar sagen es bleibt
weiterhin unsere absicht den eurofighter
durch der index generations of cars ab
2040 schrittweise zu ersetzen und das
trinationale programm öfters als
beispiel europäischen zusammenhalt auch
zu verwirklichen das habe ich letzte
woche noch mal meiner französischen
kollegin in der früh bestärkt das ist
uns ganz wichtig dass wir da die
zusammenarbeit weiter fortführen und was
die entscheidung zur tornado nachfolge
durch f-35 für unsere luftwaffe bedeutet
wird ihnen nun der inspekteur der
luftwaffe herr gerhard sports erläutert
danke
auf putins aggressionen kann es aus
meiner sicht nur eine antwort geben und
das ist geschlossenheit in der nato und
glaubwürdige abschreckung und genau
deshalb weist jetzt richtig die
entscheidung so zu treffen für die 35 es
war jetzt ohne alternative die f35 ist
das modernste kampfflugzeug weltweit und
viele unserer partner gerade hier in
europa haben sich ebenfalls für dieses
flugzeug entschieden zusammen mit
unseren partnern im bündnis werden wir
so unsere fähigkeit stärken den nato
luftraum zu sichern
glaubwürdig abzuschrecken und
unser bündnis wenn es sein muss auch zu
verteidigen
w35 ist ein kampfflugzeug der fünften
generation und es mag verfügbar und ich
denke auch hier setzte mir gerade das
richtige zeichen dass wir uns für einen
markt verfügbares system entschieden
haben damit wir die modernisierung der
streitkräfte
beschleunigen können
zudem wie unsere minister schon
ausgeführt hat werden wir auch den
eurofighter für den elektronische kampf
befähigen zusammen mit dem eurofighter
für ihren elektronischen kampf und die
f35 ist die luftwaffe damit sehr gut für
die zukunft aufgestellt und daher bin
ich auch unsere ministerin sehr dankbar
dass wir das jetzt in die tat umsetzen
können
vielen dank